Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I am your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Alright. By the way,...
...this mark means money in Japanese, right?
But this is only in Japan.
Do you know how we do it in the States?
We go like this because most money is paper in America.
So, when someone goes like this we're talking about money.
But be careful, both of them are not so polite. So, be careful where you use it, okay?
Alright. Today's topic...
The change is for you.
Thank you! The change is for you.
This is for you.
Thank you! This is for you.
The tip's on the table.
Thank you! The tip's for you, it's on the table.
Okay, let's practice.
First, the change is for you.
The change is for you.
Please repeat.
Good.
And second, this is for you.
This is for you.
Repeat.
Good.
And last, put the tip there and say,...
..."Thanks! The tip's on the table."
The tip's on the table.
Alright.
Use English like this and you'll all be a native very soon.
Thank you very much!